ses plaies. Mathieu Gohier.
- Des chants,
de la sauge brûlée, un hommage
spontané aux 215 enfants enlevés
de leur famille pour être placés
au pensionnat de Kamloops.
Ivy Chelsea s'est rendue sur
place pour que les esprits
de ces enfants oubliés puissent
enfin rentrer à la maison.
Ses parents ont vécu eux-aussi
dans un pensionnat.
Pour cette femme à la fois
mère et grand-mère,
la douleur est vive.
Même si, à Kamloops,
l'histoire du pensionnat est
connue, l'ampleur de l'horreur
dépasse l'entendement.
Devant le bâtiment, le monument
commémoratif aux élèves
autochtones est devenu un lieu
de recueillement.
Autochtones et blancs
se succèdent pour y déposer
des fleurs ou écrire un mot
à la mémoire des disparus.
- Pour la communauté
de Tk'emlúps te Secwépemc,
beaucoup de questions
demeurent sans réponse.
Mais la Première Nation est
déterminée à faire toute la
lumière sur ces disparitions.
- Encore sous le choc
et la douleur, la communauté
veut tout faire pour guérir.
Les cérémonies rituelles seront
entamées sans tarder pour que la
vie puisse reprendre ses droits.
Entretemps, les recherches
ne font que commencer.
Un rapport plus détaillé
sur la découverte
des 215 dépouilles sera publié
dans les prochaines semain